for god's sake this man cannot remain in  [Music]  and  power  open light  decency and dignity of freedom and  possibilities  [Music]  don't even think  about  moving on one single inch of nato  territory we have a sacred obligation  under article 5 to defend each and every  inch of nato territory  for the full force of our collective  power  from a russian perspective  those remarks along with the  military support provided for the  ukrainians the sanctions imposed on the  financial institutions works of art in  russia are widely interpreted here as an  attempt to silence uh and further  isolate  russia and this explains why most of the  officials talking to the media are  saying that this is something which  will only ultimately help consolidate  our identity and bring the russians  united